Mandy Moore shares a heartwarming post  for this is us co-star milo ventimiglia  'he's 40th birthday because he's milo  and he's sweet  [Music]  happy birthday to everyone's favorite TV  dad and as Mandy would say quote the  greatest TV husband Milo Ventimiglia  that this is us star celebrated the big  four Oh on Saturday and his 33 year old  on-screen wife took to social media to  celebrate sharing this adorable snap of  the pair smiling laughing and matching  in black and white ensembles captioning  the pic in part happiest birthday to the  greatest guy  we are all so lucky to know you and be  in your orbit Milo can't wait to get  back on set and celebrate with you next  week season two of this is us premieres  this fall on NBC  I'm looking forward to getting back on  set with all my friends  [Music]  you